when i was a child very first thing that
my mom told
me was not to even whisper because the
birds
and mice could hear me if somebody say
one wrong thing
it kills entire three generations of
that family
there was no internet one channel on tv
what were the subjects you guys took in
school
even like learning math was like there
are four american masters
you killed two of them then how many
american pastors
left to care we don't play with the
barbie doors we play with
tanks even kids have to go see the
public execution
my mind my imagination i just went there
so for me it's tough to kind of come
back but
painful stuff you talk about that
doesn't sound real to the average person
if you see the satellite photo north
korea is
literally the darkest place on earth and
in the posters
how american looked like was green eyes
and
humongous nose so in america the
government makes money through taxes
how does north korea make money north
korea is not a poor country
they sell drugs they sell missiles they
steal a lot of money through hacking
they serve their people
china has a responsibility to protect us
but
they capture us negotiating our price
like
dogs there is no dignity there is no
freedom for us
in china the only way to get anything
done with north korea is to get things
done with
china this regime kept this going for
over
70 years there do you know how many
north korean defectors right now in
america
over 70 years of time 200.
my guest today has i would say the most
interesting story we've ever had
on valuetainment you'll find out here in
a minute why her name is yanomi park
she wrote a book called in order to live
she escaped north korea at 13 years old
found her way
to china uh eventually south korea
eventually dublin u.s all over the place
and she's now resides in u.s she gave a
talk back in 2014
at the one young world in dublin which
within two days her
eight minute talk got 50 million views
let me say this one more time
50 million views in two days and from
there she's been a phenomenon because
she's given
us the world a glimpse of what it really
is like to live in north korea not from
what msnbc tells us
not from what cnn tells us not from what
fox tells us
her point of view of what it was like
living there for uh
13 years and so with that being said
janome park thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment
thank you so much for having me it's a
real honor to be on your show
it's great to have you so you know me
let's go back
for for those of us who have never
visited north korea all we've seen is
the videos
all we've seen is you know we've read
about it we've seen articles about it
we've seen different things about it
what was it like for you growing up in
north korea
yeah so i think that was the almost like
the biggest challenge for me to talk
about my experience
in north korea is that sometimes i
feel like if it's even easier to explain
about
mars or the moon to americans then north
korea
like north korea is a country that has
so many pieces right
the life that kim jong-un the dictator
has
is absolutely different from the
people's lives that
i had and my friends had so
i think today i i am going to talk about
the people who are in the
not in that privileged in a one percent
class but the majority of north koreans
how they are actually surviving every
day i think it's just almost like a
unimaginable everyday life is
a struggle you know in north korea yeah
when i was growing up
there were even no words for depression
so or even stress so as i growing up as
a child when i came to south korea they
told me
like stress is like very big you know
cause for something depression is
like big main cause for suicide and i
was like what is that and
you don't know what stress is like what
you don't know what depression is
and in north korea the regime didn't
put that words in the dictionary for us
so you know imagine that in
socialist paradise how can you possibly
stress
how can you be possibly depressed
but in our real life is a struggle but
we just don't know how to put those like
concept into words
i think you know when i was a child
first very first thing that my parents
my mom told
me was not to even whisper
because the ma the birth and mice could
hear me
and as a young girl the first thing i
learned is that
the most dangerous thing in my body that
i got is
my tongue what if i slip some wrong
words
that is not gonna only kill me that is
not gonna only kill my family
it is going to kill three generations of
of my family if somebody say one wrong
thing
political statement is not gonna just
kill
that person it kills entire three
generations of that family
and that is like so in that sense i
never knew what you know freedom of
speech
i somehow thought that's how a normal
world was
because there was no internet obviously
i never heard the word
internet in north korea there is only
one channel on tv 24 hours
that is telling us how wonderful the
socialist paradise is
and how bad our american ambassadors
enemies are and you know
i remember when i came to america going
to walmarts
and going to see this like section of
magazines
right they have living like magazine
fashion magazine
cook magazine i never seen any kind of
magazine north korea
like in every single cookbook there's
like i never heard of
what modeling was like there's no
fashion magazine
the regime the government telling us
what to wear
what kind of haircut you can have what
kind of makeup you can have
what kind of pants you can wear what
kind of song you can sing
what kind of movie you can watch what
kind of dance you can dance
every little thing is determined
by the regime even before i was born
and even where i live who i can marry
what can i do in life is determined by
my political class in the
in the country so telling americans that
although people who free people like
they think
you know like you choose what major you
study
what clothes you wear everything for
them is so natural but coming from north
korea
even picking up a pants was a struggle
for me like
how i choose among like 10 different
pants they are selling how do i choose
like what i like
because in north korea nobody asks me
like what do i think that's that's
that's
wild when you think about it by the way
to have that kind of an experience and
did you did you experience any i know
you said the most powerful weapon you
have is your tongue because if you say
something it could
hurt three generations not just yourself
your parents your grandparents etc etc
but you know there has to be an element
of somebody being rebellious
and if there was somebody that was
rebellious if you do remember
what typically happened to somebody that
was rebellious against a regime like
that
so like in school right at
school i didn't go to school i didn't
learn about the revolution or democracy
or none of that
things that i learned is like how brave
like what kind of miracles our dear
leader can do
and how bad the west the democracy the
the world was and you know everything
was brainwashing in school like even
like learning math
was like there are four american
ambassadors
you killed two of them then how many
american pastors
left to care as like five sixty years
old you say two american bastards
and the game that you play we don't play
with the barbie doors
we don't play some legos we play with
tanks you either use mud and build tanks
and say the teacher is like
why did you build this tank because like
i built this thing
because i want to kill our enemies and
be loyal to our dear leader
and like we build this snowman in school
and we bring like hot boiling water and
pour on top of the snowmen
and that snowman we makes like american
monster
and we say hey american enemies are gone
so that's the education
so there was really no concept of being
a
distant or being a re rebellious
but i'm sure there was that's why you
see constantly see these public
executions
and see this political prison camp
people
in our neighborhoods disappear all the
time
and we always have to go to see public
you know
trial and public execution in north
korea there's no such a thing called
like concept of minor
even you're like five seven years old if
the
school teachers say you have to go see
public execution
when someone gets shot in front of your
high eyes
even kids have to go see the public
execution
and so in that situation i think
i think in some our ways we work
rebellious
like uh watching photon dvds
and that kills us but people still
risking their lives
imagine like right now we are risking
our life or watching or some kind of
movie
and in north korea people actually
literally risking their lives
to watch a movie from the free world
what what were what were some of the by
the way in my mind my imagination i just
went there so for me it's tough to kind
of come back but
what were the topics and the subjects
you had in school so did you have world
history
did you have what what were the topics
what were the subjects you guys took in
school
so again like uh i mean kim jong-un
he went to school in switzerland so
this mostly kids do go to school in
switzerland
in moscow in like in china
in europe everywhere in germany but
the most of the bottom class like which
is like 90 80 percent of population
aren't
that lucky so i'm not talking about the
majority of people in school
i didn't learn about the like big bang
of revolution i mean the evolution of
human history
i never even seen the map of the world
so i never knew like how the world
looked like
i never knew how many planets like of
course i had no idea mars
or like all these like different planets
and i never even knew actually you exist
as a iranian i never knew
like therefore they were like different
ways they existed
they told us about americans but they
only i mean we don't have internet
and we cannot like get other books so
all we can rely on is like the
like uh posters that was provided by the
regime
and in the posters how american looked
like
was with the green eyes and humongous
nose
and they said they are like cold blooded
creatures
so i never knew actually though
americans were like warm bloody
humans they said they were like monsters
and so i did not know like they were
like
african-americans they are like middle
easterners all these different ways
so in school it was really like they
taught us about
american monsters japanese imperialists
and maybe china but not so much
and all about the you know we have to
memorize the birthday of their leaders
what year they did what what year did
what
literally our school curriculum is
dedicated to learn about
like the greatness of the dear leaders
and what it's like uh
they literally copy the bible if you
think about it
so they put kimier song as the god
who loved us who was chosen by this
universe
and loves us so much he gave us his son
kim jong-ir
which is jesus and their body dies like
jesus
but their spirit is with us forever
and when we die we become with them and
we go like
eternal paradise with them so that's why
they can like a brainwashes to think
even in my thoughts they can read my
thoughts like god
you know it was like literally they just
like copy the bible put their names
and make us like like read and learn
bible in school
and become just like complete like a
brainwashed
so did you say do you remember the enemy
number one was u.s number two was japan
did you say three is somewhat china or
it was they are going to go back and
forth they said sometimes china helped
us
but sometimes like china has no
principle they like you know
gave up and gave up the communists like
all that wonderfulness
and like gave into you know the corrupt
capitalism
but they were like going back and forth
on china but they were consistently
consistently hating america in japan
from the very beginning i remember who
who made the most money in north korea
meaning
um was it business owners was it doctors
you know who was it that made the most
money so
doctor the medical doctor salary
is one dollar and you cannot buy even
few kilograms of rice with that
so so in north korea
you have to be corrupt
the government's jobs is not gonna the
salary you get from your job is never
gonna feed you even like two days
yourself so only way to
people to survive is is corrupt and that
is why
all these government officials are
taking advantage and abusing people to
even
for them to be greedy and for us to be
you know surviving in any way possible
so people in the bottom you know i grew
up eating you know grasshoppers that was
only my source of protein i could get
and i was eating plants i was literally
finding everything i could to
find food in nature i didn't grow up
with like a refrigerator
i didn't grow up like washing machine i
went to like uh
you know river in the summer to take a
bath in the river
and wash my clothes there and you know
in the winter time we don't take a bath
maybe we take
once before the new years and like
our life is like um
i don't know how people live in 15 16th
century actually i read in textbooks but
probably close to that ancient time like
it's uh like i think the word clock
going
forward but when you look at the north
korean people's clock
is like going backwards you know if you
see the satellite photo
north korea is literally the darkest
place on earth
like you don't see any electricity in
north korea other than pyongyang
like you should like google like photo
and see what
it looks like in north korea like it is
the darkest place
and so people's lives are very
very just like there's no way like you
know people like
i escaped for hunger i risked my life
for the border rights i didn't escape to
be free
i didn't even know what freedom was like
in north korea as i said like there is
no concept of human rights
so when i heard like animals rights
i couldn't like believe like how come
animals have
rights why in north korea people don't
even know they have rights as
humans and you know they don't teach us
about freedom or individual rights or
none of that so
when i was escaping i was just literally
wondering if i go to china which is at
night time when i was in north korea we
don't have electricity
but china had electricity so far away i
could see electricity coming from china
i thought maybe if i go where the lights
were
i might find something to eat and that's
why i escaped and i came here all the
way here but
that is how most people are living in
north korea right now
i i i think you said somewhere where
once you had the
uh kim yong-goon that saw uh 80 people
who were
either watching a movie or they were
reading the bible what what happened
with that story and did you witness it
yourself
it was after i escaped in once and i
think
area there was almost like 100 people
she just executed them all in the i
think in the big stadium we import
everybody in that town
and they were their crimes were like
watching phone dvds
reading bible and and i think that was
it
really just like watching photo movies
and just
reading bibles somehow secretly they did
and that is the crime people being
executed in north korea right now what
did you look forward to as a kid what
was exciting for you like what was
fun oh i can't wait to go do this with
my sister my dad my mom what was it that
you look forward to
i mean there is like you know like when
you're born in north korea like
life is a struggle so you don't really
expect
life to be a happy thing or
something to be nice i think
my dream as a child was
uh eating a bucket of bread
so i never like really ate until i felt
like
full so i never knew like
how much i actually could eat and then
be
satisfied with it so i actually
thought when i was a child like i could
eat the like you know
mountain of like bread maybe i will
never get full
because i was always hungry and i always
like betting these games with my sister
like
i can like eat ten thousand bread and my
sister i can eat one million bread like
i can eat more than you you know
so my dream was like having a one bucket
of bread
and that was um an unimaginable thing to
do in north korea we are so poor we can
never do that so
i just never knew i was going to achieve
my dream that only
did you did you ever get a chance to
watch movies there because in iran they
were bootlegging people were bringing
movies in and all that stuff
were you able to watch any movies when
you were in north korea yeah i did i
watched
uh titanic and i
that was the point it wasn't like
changed
my mind or none of that you know you're
you're so brainwashed like
it takes a long time to de-brainwash
somebody too right
and i think i watched the movie and
first time
i was watching titanic i was just so
confused
you know why anyone make a movie out of
such a shameful story like in north
korea there's
no movie no songs no books
about love story and the like word
love doesn't exist i never seen my
father saying i love you to my mom or my
parents never told me they loved me
only love that we knew was a written
word that we could use to describe our
feelings to only be a leader
it wasn't a word that we can use to
describe our feelings to another human
being
so watching that movie like where we are
now a lot
like you know do the kissing or holding
hands in public
i was so shy like they are so corrupt
why would you make movie out of such a
shameful story
and then it was an art like you see this
man
like man dies for love and that
eventually
maybe like you know you can't actually
die for someone other than dear leader
or the revolution
because every movie that i was seeing
until that point was like you're
supposed to die
for the dear leader and that was the
most honorable death
you can get so i think that's the time
and i got
really tiny little taste of freedom so
in america we make the government makes
money through taxes right companies have
jobs you know they create jobs
there's corporate taxes there's sales
tax there's different kind of tax and
because of the citizens are you know
they make a hundred thousand dollars
they pay 35
000 in taxes companies they run a
company they pay 223
in taxes where does revenue come for
north korea to do the things that they
want to do how does north korea make
money
where do you want me to begin they sell
drugs
so they literally planted drugs
they are the biggest black market for
weapons to the middle east
they serve missiles they sell drugs
uh they serve their people they do human
trafficking the regime does
do you know all this go to africa there
are a lot of dictators
north korea send their workers slave
workers to build
statues for african dictators
and the regime served these people to go
to siberia to code all those woods
send them to qatar send them to poland a
lot of european countries
send them to china and the regime
gets all the money but these people are
in this
kind of in when they're in the foreign
place at camp
and they just work for the deal leader
and so treatment trafficking drug
selling
uh weapon selling and they do a lot of
hacking cyber security they steal a lot
of money through hacking they like
generate billions of dollars now
through hacking cyborg so that's why i'm
saying like north korea you have no idea
what a harm that north korea is
inflicting in on the world people think
oh it's nobody's business
i'm not like dictated by kim jong-un
it's not it's not my business but no
north korea raising these armies of
cyber attackers they are always hacking
and stealing
and selling weapons selling drugs
and also the you know the people in
north korea are like free slaves
the regime as i said like they pay one
dollar to a doctor
and what do you think they're gonna like
pay to uh in north korea
a man needs to serve in the military
mandatory military service
every man who is above 138 centimeters
do you know how that short is like 138
centimeters i'm not sure is that even
like four feet
at all the center is 30 centimeters it's
not tall
it's not tall i mean i'm 190 so what is
138 138 is the
four four eight so
like because of your notes so
manufactured
our height is so so so short now you're
getting short and short
and the regime says if anyone is above
138 centimeter
let's go to military for 13 years
and during the military service 13 years
you are the farmer you are the
constructor
you do every manual labor and they don't
even feed you
so you are completely mannerished and
that is
how the regime make money by
owning 25 million slaves you make them
hackers
you you test on them like body of
medical has on them you say all crazy
things on them
you just abuse them and you sell them
and you use them and that's how
the dictator can be uh you know
the god of 21st century
let me ask you this when they send these
folks out the slaves out to go help
siberia
build a statue in africa and all this
stuff how often
how do they hold them accountable so
they don't escape and not come back
so right they check through their family
backgrounds they make sure their family
has no like
bad you know political prisoners so they
checked their
vigorously their family like backgrounds
how royal they were
and they hold their families as a
hostage so they keep
keep their children when this man goes
to phone
things they have to be married and have
kids
yeah they keep their child and mother
wife and everybody as a hostage
and they also when they go to the
foreign place
it's not like they are lingered to those
that foreign society
they build their own camp and keep it
all those banners the like or do the all
those like self
criticism session and they cannot go
outside
outside the camp there are like police
secret police going with them
so when they go to abroad it's not like
they're like us
can go to supermarket whenever they want
they're in the camp and
they're completely completely controlled
by the regime
even when there is like out abroad so
so it's you know you listen to this
stuff and you
the average viewer is going to say this
sounds like a movie there's no way this
is really happening
and all the stuff that you're talking
about it's still happening till today
yes
happening right now it is okay
so what what got you i know with
your father if you want to share what
happened with your father's health but
what got you to the point as a 13 year
old
kid to say i'm leaving i can't do this
in order to go find food what
what got you to that breaking point to
leave
it was a hunger i mean i mean like i
remember
like in if you leave the potatoes out it
becomes
frozen outside and becomes like brown
and dark
you know and that was only our source of
food
by the time when you're living and north
korea is a very cold place
especially where we were like it cannot
get to like minus 37 celsius at night
and in the winter time and there's no
like heating there's no
nothing or and if you go to mountains
all the like trees were gone because
people had to find something in nature
to
make fire and cook food and
and by the time you're weird that point
we just couldn't find it anymore like
frozen potatoes
and and that's why i thought like
oh what do we do and we you see people
like
are starving to death you see and
all i could see was luckily i was in the
border area of north korea
and i thought that was maybe
last thing i'm gonna do before i die i
will try to go
cross that river to china and
we where they had all the lights maybe i
can knock on somebody's or
ask for food they might be nice to give
us some food
because in north korea i heard so many
rumors that
you know in china dogs eating rice
and i thought like it's almost like the
humor like in a rumor you hear like they
are like people living on mars you know
and it was like aliens exist like that
kind of rumors like
how can possibly dogs eating rice in
china
so let me go see china and see if that's
real and if i can get like some more
bowl of rice
and you know when you're so hungry like
you
actually want to die when you are eating
you when you're hungry you like loses
your humanity
you're not human you're not savory the
civility is only possible when you are
fed
when you are that hungry it's just
no matter what you just want to eat
that's like you know if you don't eat
you're gonna die
that's human instinct so it was like
almost
there's like a almost thing in north
korea even the ghosts
who died while they are eating they
don't have any wishes
so we don't feel bad for someone who
were dying while they were eating
that's okay if the earthquake like hits
them
what as long as they were eating it's
okay and that's
how food is like essential part for
north koreans to be
and the regime especially i think that
is the thing i want to mention to people
is that
they think north korea is like poor
that is why people are starving north
korea is not a poor country
they build like this most advanced
missiles
you know they build like ice i mean i
think all these most
advanced technical like nuclear weapons
that's why
america like trump goes away all the way
to singapore to
make kim jong-un because north korea's
military power
is that like threatening and they spend
billions of dollars on making these
nukes
and the kim jong-un the kim's the
dictators on purpose
not to feed us because
imagine if you are fat now you're going
to start reading books
now you're going to start thinking about
the meaning of life
you're going to do art you're going to
do
you you want to have your hobby you want
to think about more than surviving
so like if you keep feeding people
they are not going to be obeyed you
cannot you're not going to be able to
control them
that is why the regime so causes
calculating
not to feed us so all we can think is
not about revolution not about freedom
not about how people living it's about
surviving next meal
can we can we like survive until like
tomorrow
that's all we think as a people
when you escaped and you when you went
to uh
china and eventually south korea
what was that experience like i've read
some horrific things that you
experienced
when you were going there with the
experience of having to bury your own
father
at 3am in the morning and you and your
mother
being attacked by men and asking to
you know trying to rape you and it's
you again you you listen to these
stories and one
on one end you don't want to hear these
stories because it's so hard to listen
to stories especially as a man who has a
kid and
i'm married i got three kids i got a
daughter and i'm just thinking about
those thoughts but at the same time if
you don't talk about it
then the people around the world are not
going to realize how bad things are so
it's very
conflicted because i'm sure you don't
enjoy talking about this stuff regularly
because it's constant re-reminder
so if you don't mind if you're
comfortable sharing with that do you
mind sharing with us what were some of
those things that happened to you on
your way to south korea
i know i think i'm so grateful what you
just mentioned like you
actually when you began our interview
you said like oh this is a story that
what
cnn or msnbc or fox doesn't talk about
right
in to right now in china in 2020
there are about 300 north korean
defectors in
china right now are hiding
and being sold as a human slaves right
now
and i was one of them we hear about this
boko haram girls
we talk about these girls captured by
isis we give the nobel peace prize and
we know these girls exist but we don't
talk about the women
who are being sold like the isis
captures in china
because china is uh
everyone has economic interest in china
in in this world right now
so they purposely ignore us that we
exist
and so when i escaped to china
in 2007 i was
13 years old my sister few days before
me
escaped i wanted to go with her but
because i had a very bad stomachache
my parents took me to hospital but you
know in north korea we don't have like
x-ray machines and see what's wrong with
you literally just doctor rub your belly
and say oh my god i think she got some
like appendix
she needs to do the surgery right now
otherwise it's gonna pop this afternoon
so that afternoon they cut my belly open
without any painkiller
and then like what they found was not
even appendix it was just like
infection and malnutrition that's why i
had a very bad
stomach ache and they still like removed
my appendix
i was keep fainting and it's a very
common thing we just do surgery like no
painkiller in north korea they like cut
bones when there's no painkiller
and then and what shocked me the most is
like
nurse in the hospital she literally uses
a one meter
to inject everybody and like you use
like
pure butters to add like a drop
and you see like um dead bodies
riding from house bitter like piled up
and you know you see like rats eating
human eyes first
and you still kids chasing those rats
because even rats are very precious like
protein and kids eat those rats but
those rats have some infection by eating
human flesh at her
the kids die then vets hit us back
and and that's the point we thought like
we gotta get out of here even if we die
on the journey we are gonna get out of
here
so my sister escaped at 16 with her
friend
and a few days later as soon as i got
out of the hospital
my mom and i followed her to china
through a broker but we didn't ask why
this broker was helping us
we're so desperate we didn't even like
it didn't really matter why that person
was helping us
we were dying anyway so we crossed the
frozen river to
from china to and north korea to china
but
when i started for crossing it's like it
sounds very easy
crossing the river right but every few
meters in north korea
inside there are guards with machine
guns
standing there and they have the shoot
to kill order
so if they see anyone crossing the
frozen river you don't even ask you
don't need to even ask them to
wait you can just shoot them and that is
the order from the regime
but the broker that we we were following
had like drive the guards on that spot
so we were able to cross it without
getting shot but if you want to cross
without broker you're going to get shot
that's why
most of north koreans cannot escape
as soon we arrived in china side the
first thing i was saying
my mom was being raped by this chinese
broker
and he was trying to raid me but i just
got up like i was like
something 60 something pounds i'm still
like 80 pounds but i was like
way smaller and my mom was protecting me
and then they said
if you want to survive in china uh you
have to be soared
as uh sexual slaves
it was 2007 like 21st century
i never thought like we can sell human
beings like
dogs like puppies right
they were these chinese brokers came
negotiating our price like real like a
puppies
on the market and my mom was stored for
in this 21st century for 65 dollars
like less than my phone in my hand and
my price was
higher than hers over two hundred
dollars
because i was virgin so they paid less
than three hundred dollars to buy me
and separating me from my mom so i was
got separated from my mom at 13
right there she sorted to a farmer
and they sorted me out to another broker
and the man who bought me he he he was
already married he was a lot older than
me but he said
oh i want to keep you you're a virgin
most of north korean girls actually by
the time they go to the second broker
they all raped so nobody's virgin
but i fought so hard the first broker
that he wasn't able to successfully to
ring me
so the second broker got me as a virgin
i was very precious
for that market i was 13 and virgin
he wanted to kill me for himself and i
was going to kill myself and he said
oh if you become my mistress i'm going
to bring your parents
to me to me he was going to save my
parents for me
and i thought oh if i sacrifice myself i
can save my father i can save my mom
that's how i became his mistress at 13
and he bought my mom from a farmer
that he sold previously and brought my
sick father
from north korea but my father
was in a in a prison camp and tortured
and got a
colon cancer he couldn't make it uh
and passed away three months later
and that's when i had to bury his ashes
in the middle night in china because
chinese authority catches and sent us
back north korea to be killed
even though that goes against geneva
convention
that goes against in any international
law
that should protect political prisons
like escapees because
north koreans are not just like economic
migrants
when we escape that means we defy the
regime
and we become political like uh
refugees so the china has a
responsibility to protect us but they
capture us
and send us back north korea so we can
be executed and tortured and sent to
prison camp the only reason
only way for north korean to survive in
china
is hiding and being sold and being raped
eventually i've walked across the
scoby desert from mongolia from china to
mongolia
in 2009 with my mom and that's how i
became from
from mongolia to south korea but right
now there are still girls like me 10
15 years old even 10 years old are being
sold in china
but nobody mentions about these women
exists
because we don't want to accept chinese
regime
because they are the almighty god now
they got this economic power
um when you first got to china and you
got the
experience a little bit of freedom if
you did was it china that you
experienced some freedom or was it more
south korea when you got a taste of it
definitely south korea i mean i mean
this
guard these brokers even follow you to
your bathroom
because they don't want you to run away
we are their property of course they
don't treat us like
humans they bought us they rape us
whenever they want they say like
you're less about you're like less
worthy than even peak
even if i kill you right now nobody
gonna care nobody no police can arrest
me
i can kill you if if i want to kill you
i can kill right now
and that's what this chinese men like
telling us
so there is no dignity there is no
freedom for us in china
only way for us to be human is going to
south korea or coming to america
when you went to south korea and you
first experienced freedom
uh what what was your reaction was it
i don't believe this i can't believe
this is this real
uh emotional tears shock what what was
your reaction that you remember
i think if you are being oppressed from
the
from your parents grandparent generation
right
by the time you're born you're like numb
that is the like do you remember the
when winston comes out he's just being
numb
that's what you are it's not like when
you come out of north korea
you don't even know what culture shock
is you're like completely
numb you don't even know how to make
connections
you don't even know what to be shocked
about it's just like being completely
being numbness
it it even means i'm still recovering
just
to fear things i don't i use not feeling
a lot of things
and i think a lot of north koreans do
feel that like you just
don't fear things much and you don't
even know when you're supposed to fear
something
right you are just not used to feeling
things and
all of that is surprised so first time
when i was being free like was someone
asking
me to introduce myself
and i did not know what introduction was
you know in north korea nobody like
introduced their steps right and they
said like oh
introduction is easy you say your name
maybe what's your favorite like
what you like to do what's your hobby if
you don't even know that you can tell me
what's your favorite color it's easy
and in north korea like the regime told
me my favorite color was red
because that was a revolutionary color
or i mean my favorite country was north
korea
because that was you know so everything
was determined
for me and so and in south korea
suddenly they're asking me
my name and like okay i say my name and
they asked what's the hobby
never heard like what hobby was in north
korea no one can afford to have a hobby
so you know being free wasn't like
something
easy at all it was so painful
at some point i thought if someone not
gonna kill me
and giving me enough food in north korea
like just
keep giving me like frozen potatoes and
no one like hurt me
i actually would go back to place where
everything was decided for me
because you know understanding freedom
was a responsibility was
scary right if i choose to become
let's say dancer right i have to be
responsible
for that choice for the rest of my life
and that was insanely scary idea i had
to choose
unbelievable what you just said yeah
free meaning being free is not easy you
think it's easy
and it is not i think that's why a lot
of people actually
asking for government to be cheating for
you because
i can like it is it is only a courageous
person to be free
and onto their own like choice
and you know take that as like
accountability
so it is a very hard thing to do
you know the way you put it especially
since your entire life somebody has made
decisions for you and now it's all on
you so
you're no longer relying on somebody
where they've told you what to do now
you got to decide for yourself so
what do you want to do and you're kind
of confused you're afraid you don't know
what to do
was there an element of saying oh my
gosh i have too much freedom right now i
kind of want to go back was there any
feeling like that or not at all you were
you were saying there's no i'll take
anything except the life i had in north
korea
i definitely for sure definitely not
outside north korea but the thing is
that
if there was some kind of miracle exists
saying that the regime is not gonna kill
me and give me food for the rest of my
life not even good food just like
frozen potatoes if that's enough then
i'm like i would go back
that's what i said i was like and some
defectors
believe it or not do go back oh i
i i totally understand i totally get
that part
what was the tipping point for you where
you said i think i got this
i think i can stand on my own two feet
and i think i'm going to go out there
and spread my wings
was it was it books was it a friend was
it a teacher was it a professor was it a
co-worker
what was it i think to
change somebody's life i don't know like
a lot of people say like oh this is the
moment
i changed my life but course books
was the beginning i think in south korea
i was so discriminated by south koreans
um the books was only the one that i
could like
rely on and the also the thing another
challenge is that you know when when i
were arrived in south korea
these people saying oh korean war
started by kim
kim sung by north koreans it's like that
was started by south and american
ambassadors what are you talking about
and they say
oh kim's are not gods they're just
dictators
and at some point i was like i had
trusting issues
like so if everything that i believed
until
like this point was a lie how do i know
that you are not lying
like it is there's a question like if
it's right now
right i'm coming to you like patrick
everything you believe is a lie
do not believe anything and then you're
gonna be like
how do i know you're not lying to me
then everybody told him it was live
right
it was like that and then i couldn't
trust people
and that's when i read george orr's
animal farm
and then i read 1984 afterwards and i
was like
oh this makes sense this really makes
sense
and then i started reading more and
getting to more things and
living things and understanding what
happened but until that point
i just like i don't know i i don't think
i can trust anyone again
which character in animal farm did you
relate to the most i mean obviously
there's the pigs and the napoleon and
all the donkey
who did you relate to the most
do you remember the the last uh towards
the end
there's new pigs are being born and they
don't know what life was like
before that was me
i my grandma knew what it was like
before
kim my leave my grandmother lived under
the japanese culinary
colonization so she she worked before
him
but because they kept silent
by the time when i was born my
universe was kim my the human
human evolution started the kim like in
north korea the calendar begins with the
kimura song's birthday
yes to taiwan
that is our canon the kimura song when
he was born that's when north korean
calendar starts
we have a different time that even other
we our time begins
differently and we have a saying we
don't we are not
asians we are not like some east asian
we are kimurasang people we are keemer
song race
that's what they say we are kimura some
race
we are not asians in north korea
so in that book i was
i felt i wasn't like angry for my
grandma
generation who kept styling but
it was so sad by that new generation
that new pigs don't even know the time
before what it was like
and that's when i realized oh that's
what happened to me
and i think this is why i need to
understand
what my grandma went through what my
parents went through what i am going
through
uh fascinating by the way uh did kim
get the kim young i mean his family his
father did they think they're god
is that how they saw themselves like is
it
a second coming how do they view
themselves
i is it more profit or is it more god
oh it definitely prof i mean definitely
god it's not a prophet lover it's like
uh
kim your son is a god the almighty god
who can do
perfectly anything like you when the
bible explains you are like you're a
mere human being you cannot understand
the god's the perception
you cannot challenge god's logic you got
all this higher logic right
so it's like why there's misery that's
god's way
then it expands everything you don't
need the logic to explain god's way
so that is what they do like we don't
need to
ask for logic or making any sense
because it's god
we cannot understand possible gods that
fire impression so they only
can do that when they are being god
you know there was a movie i don't know
if you've seen the book of eli you ever
seen a movie book of eli with denzel
washington or nowhere
he's blind and he has this book that he
has to touch and that's how he reads the
bible and this one man is trying to get
the bible because
back then people weren't reading and he
said if i can get the bible i can
control people's minds
but i can't teach them how to read
because if they stay dumb i can control
them and lead them
it just takes me there but but you and i
when you and i were talking offline i
was showing this painting i showed you
these two different books
and you said you read both of them one
of them is communist manifesto the other
one is at the shruck by iran
and the other one is by karl marx you
had a chance to read both of them yes
i read eighty percent and i shrugged
okay it's a big book it's a very big
book
i read five times of commerce manifesto
not because it was good i
because in north korea i was like i just
couldn't
i just wanted to read that but why this
book
this ideology killed that many people
in this world nothing has killed more
than communism
the mile killed 50 to 60 million
people i mean can you like stalin
nothing not even nazism not even like
not in poverty not even even nuclear war
nothing cared more than communism in
this world in human history
and that's why i was like i just had to
read this
this damn thing like what was this that
killed
destroyed my people destroyed my
killed my father it came to my father
and
and just it just i just had to read it
and reading reading and just make no
sense
and then it's like i just stopped there
it's like okay there's no point of me
keep reading because i just want you to
understand the mindset why they were
doing this
but it just uh
it's just so evil you sound like so nice
but
what what when it comes to soul evilness
the greed of power
control and you do not respect the very
the you don't trust the human decency
and you believe you have to control them
and like collectives and all of this is
like
completely disrespect the human dignity
why do you think the concept of
socialism
and communism and folks like bernie
sanders or aoc or even the younger crowd
that's coming up right now the other day
an
article came out from harvard saying 57
of the youth
except socialism as a way and they think
capitalism is bad
why do you think in a country where you
and i couldn't wait to get to because
this is our dream right
all these freedoms you know why do you
think this concept of socialism and
communism is so attractive in the u.s
educational system with many politicians
today in america saying america's a bad
country i mean i read an article that
came out yesterday
written by business insider by margaret
ward what's her last name margaret's uh
something like that where she set the
top five best countries to raise kids in
and the top five worst countries to
raise kids in
i think the top five worst la fifth
place was bulgaria fourth place was
turkey i don't remember who third place
was
second place was us as the worst country
to raise kids in
and first place was mexico
and and this whole concept of americans
bashing
america that we should go to european or
socialism or communism is not really
that bad
why do you think that's happening in
america and how do you view it when
people start saying things like that
i actually haven't known
i think i can understand why some people
are saying that because
you know communism was tried
and whenever it was tried they failed
right
but people bought it at that time like
people started following lenin
and like like they all did they followed
they bought the idea so i can't see
how appealing the idea is got it
and especially to young people who a lot
of people don't pay
when you're young don't pay taxes right
you don't work you don't actually
understand how
the economy really works and also
i think because now life is so easy
right like when you're born your mother
is so low especially in the u.s
i think this generation expects life to
be easy
that's what their expectation is and
like you and i know we
you're going iran i was born in north
korea you
you know that our ancestors from
go back into the time life was so
difficult for them people like fantasize
about
old days like no all day people died
from cancer so many different things
and now there's a lot of cancers can
even cure but here in america
people say like doctors say colon cancer
a lot of times it can be cured
my father never had to die if he was in
freedom
he only died because he was he was
incarnate socialists committed china
and communist societies north korea
and i think just the
only thing is that i mean if there's no
capitalism
the people i'm sure you're gonna see
this gonna criticize
they're not gonna have youtube they're
not gonna have twitter
without capitalism how any of this is
possible
capitalism is making it available for us
to have
all of this have excessive food have
opportunity
have all the device that we own today
even even
zoom do you think you can find zoom in
north korea
no there's no skype in north korea we
like capitalism how do we have
any of this and i think
this they don't and i think for me it's
like
just i don't i mean like if you
worship communism association that much
just go to north korea
why don't you just immigrate to north
korea because like everyone wants to
come to us
that's why everyone's coming here and
all these people like why don't you open
the border and give all
everybody citizenship and let them in
right that's
how demanding americans are american
citizenship is
so i mean do north korea have that
problem so if
those people really want that kind of
system i think they just should
immigrate to those places
because like you know i mean that is my
ideology if you're going to worship to
me about like the grainy socialism
go to north korea it is the last country
that pure holds
this ideology so it's it's that easy
like it's not nurture is not that far
away in in our planet
they can go and have their dream of this
being socialist
yeah i mean you know when it comes from
somebody like you
who has seen things a lot you have lived
the life of
thousands of people in oneness not the
life i mean you can't compare
the things you witness in your eyes like
if somebody was to close their eyes they
created technology to connect my brain
to yours and within a five minute period
i can witness all the things you've
witnessed the level of pain my body
would go to i probably would pass out
if i was able to witness the stuff that
you've seen with your own eyes
painful stuff you talk about that
doesn't sound real to the average person
that you only see this stuff in a movie
but you've experienced it so your
point of view is coming from a different
point of view and sometimes when you're
born in america
in in the most incredible country in the
world
that people have not seen anything else
all they want to see is the things that
it does wrong they have no club
batteries in other places
and how many people would love to come
to a place like this you know one thing
i was wondering about you was you said
something you said
you know i mean i could not trust men
again
i hated men i hated humanity how on
earth can people sell
each other right and today you're
you're married and you have a kid you
got married i think in 2018 to a
gentleman named ezekiel if i'm saying it
correctly
yes and and uh how how did that
transition for you take place
you know sometimes people go through a
bad breakup they'll say oh he cheated on
me i will never date another guy ever
again they're all dogs they're all this
uh i mean you you were you experienced
tremendous pain
how were you able to go through this
pain to say i can
love another man and continue with my
life how do you go through that
transition
i think so i am married to american
bastard
the american bastards i learned to care
and hate we do everything i had
he's american bastard he is like has a
european heritage
too so he's pure pure monster in the
eyes of north korean regime
i would be like death too right now to
marry to them is international is not
marriage is not a lot in north korea
and i have a son with him and
in my son's birth certificate it says
mother is north korean and father is
american
and when i got that birth certificate
like more than two years ago
in chicago hospital this is a
pure miracle you know this is only
possible in a country like america
it is only possible in freedom and that
a baby half north korean and american
can be born
that is only few countries in those
world we can do that is
america as a rape victim
i was raped i was shamed in south korea
as a colored person as a refugee as a
defector
and all of those things i have been
welcomed by this country and people in
this country i think
when i came to america i met
like gay men right he's like my step
brother but
in north korea i never heard the gay was
like there's nowhere to get in
dictionary
so when he like met me here hulk gave me
hug i was like
don't worry baby i'm gay and i was like
what the heck is he talking
why are you even hugging me like it's
and i went on time i looked it up gay
and i was like oh that's what it meant
but
i think just being in this country
seeing
people just accepted who they are
and i think that was a
point of me to overcoming it but it was
just so many people's kindness
it was really so many people
like you you know sympathizing my story
and wasn't saying that i was dirty or
like
any of that i think you're just really
meeting a lot of good kind people
open-hearted people i think that here to
me and by the time when i my husband
of course in the beginning i was very
suspicious i thought like
you know my first time being with men
was being raped
how can i possibly think of anything
good of them
but i think you know eventually
with a lot of support and love i
overcame it and
now i have a son and wonderful son and
i my father was a man too and i think
it was you know when you're traumatized
you cannot be really
rational that is the i think most
difficult part you cannot really tap
into your logic
fear comes regarded and you are very
scared
but i think really also understanding
what trauma was
you know i never knew what trauma was
until coming to america
and really understanding what trauma
does to your brain and your
your feelings all of it really helped me
to overcome
a lot of my you know past experience
well that that that says a lot about
your character says a lot about your
character of who you are
and i salute you for that because that's
not easy to do
especially for somebody like you and
that means a part of it also means how
much you love your father
you know it's it's to to be able to have
a fond memory of your father where you
say other men like him are
out there that are willing to do
anything for
their daughter that says a lot about who
your father was and obviously i
don't know the story about your father
but it says a lot about who your father
was
you know you you said something about
trump earlier when he went and met with
kim yong-goon how do you view trump uh
from this point of view so i kind of
want to kind of set the whole thing up
and you tell me how you view him
so here's a man in america who's the
president the most powerful man in the
world today
and on one end he goes and meets with
with kim young to try to potentially
prevent
him and persuade him to not do any kind
of nuclear because
south korea is a ally and we have
military bases in south korea army has
camp casey
and you know he's trying to negotiate to
kind of get him on his side
trump is and you know how you view him
because you live there you know exactly
what life is like living there and so
to see him go there saying why would you
go meet with the modern day
let's just say hitler you you've said
that before but then on the other side
you see him
go after china that has uh
hurt a lot of people a lot of
underground you know concentrate a lot
of things that you read about that
almost again doesn't seem real
and you see a lot of people in america
that are afraid of saying anything bad
about china because
they either have business dealings or
they're making money or if it's whether
it's hollywood
nb or some politicians so here's the
same man
that on one side meets with the dictator
that
you lived under and at the same time
goes against a regime that everybody
fears
china how do you view how trump's doing
as a president when it comes down to
these two relationships i'm so glad you
asked that question because
this is like what i learned i think from
my journey of course i learned to be
how to survive but i think one thing
that i learned the most is like really
what it means to be a human
right most of things in life is not
black and white of course like
hitler was pure black evil i do think
someone is pure
evil there are some things we cannot
discuss
either is black or white right some
things i think we have to make them
like they are completely black you know
they are evil but most of things are not
and i think even the man who bought me
who raped me at 13 who i wanted to care
but he eventually freed me to go to
south korea
that's what humans are like we are
complex creatures
i forgive that man who bought me and
raped me
and i i actually even helped that man
who
sent to prison and when he got out of
the prison in china 10 years later i
helped him
that's how i forgave him for that
but i think with the trump too i think a
lot of people think because i criticized
trump for
north korea with the one meeting that
doesn't make trump fool black
it's it's uh i
definitely understand trump's side why
he is from business background
and he doesn't understand when he meets
a
head of state the connotation in it
in north korean people's mind if a
leader of free world meets our leader
later that makes our jitter
be a little very legit trump i'm sure
not get that as much and i'm sure also
he
is a deer maker he used to make a lot of
beers so he thought
without even north korea's any
preconcession
he can go in and maybe convince kim
jong-un and come to out of the
entertainer
but i think but because he is a united i
mean the president of this country i do
have a higher expectation for him
given north korea history this regime
kept this going for over 70 years
less than 20 over 20 years it's gonna be
hundred years one century
north korea has been doing this so trump
cannot be just going in like one setting
i'm gonna convince this guy
out of 70 years of this history gonna
ask him to change that's not gonna
happen
so that is the part that i was
criticizing trump for
but that does not mean i was criticizing
every single thing that trump was doing
as a president
and i think it goes to obama it goes to
any president
i do think there are pres every
president has
pros and cons they do sometimes make
mistakes
they do right things so it's not like i
you know go against everything that
trump does but i do
completely understand that the
effect the negative fact that trump
brought
for the for the summit because that made
kim jong-un even
power forgotten you know even though the
most powerful country's backing is their
leader
and he you know complimenting him
someone saying like
he's a love he's people loving him and
you know
he's a great leader he's a tough guy and
that video to north korean people
and saying like look at him even though
american presidents are worshiping our
dear leader
and that was the problem that with the
the
tourists going into north korea do you
know there used to be a lot of
tourists going into north korea
the western like a lot of western
tourists went to north korea it's
almost like uh visiting you know these
concentration camps
you know people are like enslaved but
you have money you can go and sing this
like uh
the zoo or like you know the roller
coaster place the kingdom
created for you to see so when you go to
touring north korea you only
can't go see the guy the places that
regime allows you to see
you have to go to the guys you cannot
and do you remember like the
auto reindeer the american college
boy eventually died because he was
trying to
get like the tour is happening and they
have no freedom whatsoever but
when these people go they have to bow
in front of statue of kim and kim jong
kim jongier
and that shows the north koreans they
say everybody wants to be like north
korea
everybody wants to come to north korea
look at this white people
look at them bowing from statue of dear
leaders
they respect their leaders more than
like we do
so that's how lucky we are to have our
dear leaders
so that all information being back
played
that is the why i was really against
trump
going to mid north korea kim jong
without any concession
without any much planning and look at it
what the result
i mean i sat there nothing can happen
nothing happened
so that is the really only like context
of me engaging with like
his policy how do you how do you view on
how he is
challenging and pushing and uh you know
giving a hard time with tariffs and bans
and all this other stuff when it comes
down to china and the way he's been
dealing with china
i do i mean i do wish
i mean of course trump when it comes to
china i mean i do agree
communist chinese regime is the biggest
threat to humanity right now
i mean we talk about like climate change
we talk about
a lot of the even pandemic but the harm
that they cause is not as
little as the chinese community regime
does to
so many places in this world there are
muslims and going into
concentration camps right now you see
these millions of muslims right these
minority groups
they are being sent to prison camp
there's a massive
the violation of privacy on chinese
people
and then people speak out i think
i do think try and trump did a lot of
raising that
issue but i wish he does also focusing
on human rights angle
it's not all about just business trying
to bring the business back to america
and save the economy but
i do wish that he also understands how
the regime
chinese comes regime is like backing
backing this terrorist north korea
and keeping its 25 million people as a
slaves
and how they also in other regions like
women from
burma and like me and other regions are
sent to china to be married with farmers
in china right now
because of the one child policy their
lack of women
and that is why i was being sold as a
child bride in china
but north korean women are not the only
women being sold as a prize
a lot of other countries women are also
being affected
by this you know chinese the one child
policy and all of this current policy
so i think i think just i hope that
trump you know
i mean he's doing a lot already on china
but i hope we keep doing it and doing
more
and bringing more issues and bringing
lies to on other issues that
people didn't know where in the past so
so
ideally what would you like to see
happen so you know what's going on in
north korea
and you know what's going on in china
ideally ideally
what would you like to see happen that's
possible of happening
and how does trump or anybody go about
making this become a reality
when it comes to saving north korea one
is one is to
to show the world what is going on with
north korea instead of being an ally
because the threat is
if trump pushes too hard kim young is
capable of doing anything he's capable
of
you know putting a nuclear uh war you
know a bomb
in south korea and then that's going to
be on his hands so if he pushes too hard
kim young may do something so how do you
go about
addressing this challenge that's taking
place in north korea as well as what's
going on with
trafficking and human rights in china
so i think that is um
so north korea only exists
because of chinese communist party
no country in the world can have a trade
with north korea because the
dictatorship it's been like banned by
the u.n resolution
so china does go against the u.n
resolution
and keep aiding north korea regime i'm
not saying people the region
when i also i think one thing that
people keep confusing is that we never
said
communist party is very different from
the chinese people
i love chinese people i love chinese
food i speak chinese i love everything
about china
i love all of their like inventions in
history but
i'm talking about right now the current
regime the communist party
and that party almost sponsors
dictatorship in north korea the one
thing
gonna change north korea is cutting the
oil
imagine there's no north korea is not
oil producing country
if you stop giving them oil how they're
going to test the messiah
how they're going to keep building
missiles china
is giving them more so north korea is
keep building missiles and advance their
technology when it comes to weapons
i'm not saying cutting the food i'm not
saying cutting medical supplies
cutting the oil so north korea cannot
build any more missiles
but china is keep giving them more and i
think that is why people just don't know
what a threat the chinese communist
party and north korean regime is to the
world
that is doable i mean china was the
first
president to brought that north to south
china north korea we need to talk to
china
it is very true because you know if you
solve the relationship with china
china yourself north korea right away
but they they use almost like north
korea as kind of uh you know buffer zone
from democracy
coming into china from south korea and
japan and america
so eventually you i do think
american president whoever comes in next
or even trump is gonna be
they need to focusing on negotiating
with china even on north korea
on everything because china got the all
the right kids
and if china cuts down that oil supply
north korea going to collapse because
how do you leader going to drive his car
to visit his luxury resort
how does all these elite officials in
kangan gonna drive around
having their meetings no one can do
anything
and if china wants to help people give
them food food is fine but
don't give them more don't give them
anything that helps breeding news
but but china doesn't they keep out they
keep going against and giving them all
all the time wow and how easy it is
so so if i understand you correctly is
if china doesn't support north korea
no one else in the world is going to
help and support north korea well but it
can
okay because because of you and
everybody can't
yeah nobody is go or breaking the laws
so
like only china like illegally trading
with
north korea so china's the only one that
goes against the u.n resolution that we
have that they go out and they say we're
going to help them out anyway help them
out anyways whether you like it or not
we're going to do that okay
now china just brokered a deal with iran
for 400 billion dollars
and we know what that deal is all about
this is just the last month you can go
look it up it's a 400 billion dollar
deal with
iran it's a long-term relationship so
you know who iran's against
everybody including u.s you just saw a
deal that happened yesterday with
israel and uae and uh uh uh uh am i
saying it right
uh uae yes you're not arab yes and then
then you're seeing china now support so
it doesn't seem like the right way for
trump do negotiating with north korea
means nothing because nothing's gonna
get done
the only way to get anything done with
north korea is to get things done with
china yes so step number one for you
would be to help anything with human
trafficking or human rights
or socialism communism any of that stuff
is making sure the pressure is put more
on china and forget about north korea
because if you solve china
then you're going to be fine with north
korea is that am i hearing you correctly
exactly i think people think like
there's no way we're going to talk over
to kim jong-un and convince he changed
his mind he's not going to change his
minds
the elites in north korea are like
living like kings
imagine being a being of god in 21st
century with
all kinds of next like you know these
technological
events the best i mean sure king ever
exists in human history
so they're not gonna give that up and i
think only way we can achieve that goal
is through chinese communist party
but so far they are they don't care
about human
rights they don't care about freedom
they don't care about anything they just
care about their status goal and
maintaining
whatever they've been doing this
stability and that stability means
there's no power what happened what is
happening to north koreans that is what
the u.n said
the only resemblance we find what is
happening to north korean people is
the you know nazi the hitler time or
like stalin soviet union those
concentration camps
north korea the country is a
concentration camp
the entire country started with like
wire
fences you don't think like yeah of
course inside there's another more worse
consensus neighbors
but like nobody can leave north korea
without permission
and only if you can leave the country
and you cannot go to north korea right
now and see
i do say like there are people like elon
musk wants to go to like in a different
planet
and like you know occupy mars i mean the
moon right
i do think somehow we might go to the
like universe you know the different
planet before we land north korea fully
as a human race
that's how north korea is like left
you know out from the rest of the
humanity and i do think
it is time to bring them to our human
race and as
we moving forward how can we leave 25
million
like there in that darkness like what
does that to say
our morality right like i do think
this is a challenge that anyone should
ask like even the u.s president they
should
they should like it is so sad like how
this country is being like this for over
70 years and still like all this
political interest
everything comes first and just like
these issues are being buried
completely like this let me let me first
of all you got to be nominated for nobel
prize have they ever contacted you have
you ever spoken anybody about nobel
prize because
no no no you have you have you have what
you've experienced and what you're
talking about
that's gotten hundreds of millions of
views which at this point if you combine
facebook say billion plus views it's
something that the world needs to know
more about and i think there needs to be
a form of nomination on your end but
have you ever spoken to anybody from
trump's camp or no has anybody from
trump's camp ever reached out to you or
no
i i mean not from his campaign directly
i
did i mean
when when hillary clinton was running
the campaign
i met her and she wanted to do so i mean
she was going to do some but
you know everybody says that i met like
nancy pelosi
and she was like oh i really have my
heart for nursing people i want to do
something for it but
it is all politicians saying it and i
don't think
anyone here genuinely caring what people
are
going through in oppression right there
are so many people are oppressed and i
think
it is nobody's interest they just want
to do what is like politically right
what is it if the more likes and votes i
think there are more people
i think there are more people and i i uh
the right people watch this channel just
so you know
uh and uh we're gonna make sure they get
a chance to at least hear your side of
the story
and find a way to get a hold of you
because every time i you know
i've interviewed a lot of people i've
sat down with president bush i've sat
down with politicians billionaires
millionaires
athletes celebrities hollywood con
artists you know mobsters
it doesn't matter i've sat down with
everybody i've sat down with so many
different personalities
and i just enjoy getting to know people
and hearing people's stories
every single time i ask you a question
and i said i don't know if our answer is
going to have that much depth in it
let's see how
layer of deep your answer is going to be
okay
and most people go two layers deep three
layers deep
every question i ask you your answer's
depth was so deep where
i'm walking away learning from you and
i'm 15 years young
older than you i think you're 26 are you
26 now or
you're 26 years old now and uh uh
very very fascinating what what are some
of your aspirations i know you've
written a book i know you're
have this book out which we're going to
put the link below for people to be able
to
go out there and get it in order to live
we'll put the link below i think on
amazon it has 17 1800 reviews and it's
all five star people obviously love it
from reading and we've only had an hour
and a half hour 20 minutes to go through
stuff but
what are some of your aspirations
because you with your life
experience and what you've done you got
a very big upset i'm just curious to
know what some of your aspirations are
i think two things i think i won
at this point i mean in the past it was
like as you said right i felt like i was
i lived for a thousand years
i've i felt like so exhausted i feel so
old and i'm like only 26
too and having a baby changed a lot
about it but
and one is definitely helping my people
because um it does
like heartbreak right in america our
problem
is having too much and never understood
having too much could be a problem and
also
having no problem can be a problem too
and i just never understood this like
it's really
i just see this here like having too
much and having no problem is a problem
and how do i keep my perspective
and not getting into this this universe
of
you know complaining about having too
much and having not having actual real
problems
and i think that's what my goal trying
to maintain
my route some of them is really bad i do
want to get rid of those like
the tradition that i learned from the
regime i do want to get rid of it but
some of them i do want to preserve is
really
keeping that perspective and i want to
help my people because you know they are
do you know how many north korean
defectors right now in america
from that's over 70 years of time
200. like
200 made into america from north korea
like what is the mathematical chance of
me
crossing the desert coming here in
america
and speaking and talking to you right
right now
and i am not religious but i do think
i do feel that responsibility i do think
i don't feel that special chosen one
because just mathematically doesn't make
any sense
and as someone i think not
i mean we exist we live we this uh these
victims do exist of this human
trafficking and this regime
but you don't see a lot of like the
factors coming like iran
you know a lot of i know a lot of actors
from from iran the women's
like rights but not from north korea
because
one even after they escaped
i spoke you saw that video right in 2014
i gave everyone young words oh thank you
two months later i don't even two months
later
north korean regime captured all my
family my nephews my cousins
even my neighbors anyone knew me
put into propelling the video on youtube
and they all got vanished because i
spoke out
after my escape so you think like
i'm free right now but i'm not free
defectors
after they escape they are not still
free they are
their assassin of they actually regime
you know like kim jong-nam got like
poisoned
kim jong king the brother of kim jong in
malaysia he poisoned his brother in
where there's cctvs of course he doesn't
care killing a defector
who cares nobody gonna bother him so he
cares a lot of the factors who speak out
not only than the family members was
left behind
so the vectors when they escape and
speak out they still pay
so much price to have the voice and have
this presence unlike
a lot of other countries when they
escape they are almost like done with
their country and they can like move
forward but the factors also we cannot
move forward
we still like get right i i'm on the top
like list of the regime kim jong of
course won't scare me
and i think that's why i do want to be
free someday
from this region from this together
completely
so i can say whatever i want and i don't
get that threats
and no one dies in my family because
what i say
i think my journey to freedom still
continues
i think i'm gonna fight until i die
until i completely free from this
dictator
and also i do want to be you know
grateful and happy here because
that's where we are and i think life is
about being grateful i don't think every
day i try not to be bitter
and i i try to be just so grateful i
think when
my sister i found her seven years later
she was so bitter and she has just like
self-pity going on
and i was like you know what
is the point of you surviving
all of that insanity through and now
you're here you're complaining about
what you've gone through
like i remember like my when i was
writing my book my
publisher said like you mean you're
traumatized you have to get some therapy
it's like
what's the therapy and like you know she
told me oh here people having
difficulties they have to go like
therapy
and then i ask okay so how much is it it
was in yo it was like over 20 dollars
per hour i was like
no way i can afford it no thank you for
therapy
i didn't get therapy i think their pizza
if you can get it's a great but
my point is that like it was so hard to
survive it didn't make it this far and
i am not gonna be like here like
complaining about how difficult it was
you know and i think that is what i want
my people to do when they come out of
this tunnel
they don't feel bad about what they've
gone through but they're just grateful
oh first of all i think you're just
getting warmed up
what you're gonna do in the world i
think your impact is just getting warmed
up there are certain people that you
talk to you can tell
some tell a story and yes they want to
share the story
but some are true believers at the
highest level you are a true believer
and true believers are dangerous i'm not
surprised why
north korea is not happy with you
because it doesn't sound like you're
going to stop
until you get what you want and people
like that are very hard to find most
people would just
go and just want to be quiet and just
live a regular life and not say anything
because they don't want
more uh trouble but to have courage at
the level that you have
aristotle said the highest level of
quality for a human being to have is
courage and you have that
and that says a lot about the fabric of
your character and i applaud you and i
salute you for being who you are
and i thank you once again for making
some time
and being a guest on valuetainment and i
look forward to bringing you back again
when other events takes place
to talk to you because this has truly
been a distinct pleasure of mine
to have a conversation with you it's
been amazing so thank you so much for
your time
it's been a real honor thank you so much
patrick
now obviously this is probably one of
the most unique interviews we've ever
done for somebody to give the experience
of what it is to live in north korea for
13 years and escape and go to china
then go to south korea then come over
here then be somebody that read as much
as she did
and to get herself to this point what an
inspirational story right what an
inspirational story i want to hear your
thoughts comment below i got two other
videos i want you to watch if you enjoy
this one one of them is with an attorney
that was in china for 20 years as an
attorney gordon chang if you've not seen
this
he explains the conditions in china in
ways you probably never heard before
and the other one is with uh from epoch
times where i sat with one of the
reporters
where he explained the methods china's
using and how they're treating their
people that nobody else is hearing about
click on either one of them that you
want to watch and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody
take care bye